they got a speed here I wanted to make a
video with some tips on how the dark
purple or eith candy works and candy
crush soda and and cranny crush jelly so
you can see there that I made a striped
match with the dark candy I'm going to
do one again here I could do it up and
down or I could do it you know left to
right here but what it does is it makes
sort of a super stripe where the whole
thing clears out the board instead of
just a stripe in the middle here we can
make the T shaped which is going to make
an explosion like a wrap candy all
around this area you can see how far it
goes only takes one layer off the honey
at the bottom but you can see how big
the radius it has here so it's a good
it's good for you know a small space
when you want to clear it out here I
could make the T again or striped the
striped won't take out the bottom row
all the way but you can see it made a
little bit of damage on the layer so I
went with that one there and this so
basically the way that it works the dark
purple candy is any special match you
make with it it activates right away and
it gives you a really cool a really cool
special effect right right at that time
you can make all the special matches
with it you would see the fish here in a
second like here I could make the stripe
that would clear everything out or I can
make the striped at either one of those
spots I went ahead and made the fish
just so you can see it releases for fish
if you make the fish shape with four
candies it'll makes em L make five if
you make it with like a tail on top
there again it's just a regular fish
shaped match a square and then like I
said it will send off as many excuse me
don't make out he'll send off as many
fishes you have candy in the match there
goes our four so one of the things one
of the things to keep in mind with this
is that it works exactly the same in
candy soda and in jelly saga so I'm
going to go ahead since this is a skinny
board here I'm going to go ahead and
switch games and talk about the bigger
matches on a board that has a little
more room so I can set them up but it's
alright you know this is a feature I
really liked when it first came out and
so yeah here we go in jelly and I'm
going to try to make a color bomb match
and a coloring candy match yeah it's a
feature I really liked when it first
came out and soda and so I was really
excited to see that they left it in
jelly the same way there you can see I
made a striped match with it and you can
see that it cut it covered where it hit
the jelly it spread it all the way along
the line same here
you know if you you know it's it'll
spread it just like it does with any
other special it's you know same with
the the rats less of striped you know
spread it in both directions so we'll
hopefully get some hit we get a place
where we can set up the there's a fish
dark purple fish little got a place here
where we can set up a color bomb or
coloring candy match before too long way
this is a good board for it because it's
wide open and they fall down pretty
liberally okay so here is the coloring
candy one so you can see that it doesn't
leave anything behind it just goes
straight into the mode where it will
paint all the colors dark or all the
kingdoms dark purple and you see a bunch
of fish take off and there was color
bomb explosion in there but since there
wasn't much to cover up left and I'll
just drop things into place down here
and hopefully set up a color ball match
quickly they're about equal I think on
this if there's not a lot of space that
coloring candy one can is not quite as
good because it doesn't send out the
shock wave across the whole board like
the color bomb one does but on a big
board like that one you know you
obviously got a pretty good effect
so here maybe we can drop down we can
set this up drop the dark one down from
the top
get a color bomb we got a brute candy in
the way but else maybe we can drop one
from the top here we got our yeah there
we go
so now we just got to drop one into
place and there it is and you'll see
this will send out a shockwave explosion
and cover the whole board in jelly
because it will set off on the on the
jelly and you know if there were
blockers out there it would take a layer
off all the blockers just like a regular
color bomb except for you don't have to
activate it it goes off automatically a
couple things to keep in mind when
you're playing jelly saga that are
different than soda saga when it comes
to these dark purples is that if you're
playing one of the bosses like clean or
cupcake Carl
here's another color bomb one it doesn't
give you an extra move it doesn't stun
them like making a special candy does so
that's it's kind of annoying but as long
as you know that going into that it's
just not going to give you an extra move
um other than that they work the same in
both games it's a it's a really cool
feature it's pretty easy to understand
after you play around with it I don't
know it's pretty much in jelly saga
towards you know the towards the
beginning it doesn't come in to soda
saga until later in the game but you
know if you got any more questions about
how it works you can leave them in the
comments and I'll try to answer them for
you and you know just use it like you
would specials and try to get them
there's a lot of levels where you need
them to clear off like blockers and
things like that like you know without
some of the bigger purple candy matches
or they eat candy they call it because
of its the eighth color in soda saga you
know it you're going to need to get them
to drop so you know if you're having
trouble getting past the ball with a
bunch of blockers or
you know where you need to spread the
jelly or something like that start
making matches from the top that'll get
more pieces to drop on the board and
it'll set it up so like I said if you
have any questions leave a comment and
I'll try to answer it please like the
video if you make a knew how to play
videos with commentary like this with
tips so please subscribe to my channel
to help support it and I'll talk to you
soon thanks